so okay I'm gonna play another game play
one more game getting distracted here
oh it's detecting my stream that's
beautiful okay and I'll switch okay so
people should see the board playing a
17-hundred this requires full focus he
six interesting
you
he's six
take I think I can take my g5 oh no
there's a pawn on e6 oh but the opponent
gets something trapped
there's opponent each six rights we
Bishop I'm not free bishop
position is this default coming
because I didn't develop my bishop yet
my night
fuse
Queen on like we need to first
we got so confused
ah I can't defend you castle
this is really bad favorite t1
who's played there
weights the Queen move somewhere or the
Queen move back to c7 this is such a bad
guy I forget where things are the crook
went to f7
I just have to dirty flag my opponents
you
you
you
oh no I got needed what was that game
also what was that opening cuz there is
a pawn in h6 definitely
I forgot the pong went to c6 - I thought
I was dropping the Queen that was so bad
when I got trapped then I tried to
desperate I should have just rather to
h5 come on with a queen was their
closest to me wait it was still me it
was still me I drew I thought I got me -
oh that's so funny
I drew oh I didn't realize that's so
funny Wow I I lost track of the position
way before I think around around here I
knew I was going to lose one of these
things
me I should play this and I was just
playing around a little
well I had a chance for meets maybe
close to me I was so terrible I'll have
to put that on YouTube
that wasn't me I need me realize YouTube
people watching in the future and twitch
people watching live hope you enjoyed
that
say hi to taggi and John and I'm sorry
about your site that's okay I can I can
see now I just can't see man
this thing is on or when the pieces are
invisible
but yeah you too people thanks for
watching be sure to LIKE and subscribe
it helps the algorithm